بعد الهجمات الايرانيه المتكرره داخل
اقليم كردستان العراق وبعد ان هدد الطيران
بغداد بنشر قواتها على طول الحدود بين
الجانبين او انها ستقوم بعمليات بريه داخل
العمق العراقي ضد من وصفتهم بالجماعات
المعارضه الايرانيه المسلحه سرعت بغداد
واربيل الخطى لايجاد حل عاجل لنزع فتي
للازمه
لقواتنا الامنيه بالتعاون والتنسيق مع
اخواننا في البيشمركه خاصه على طول شريط
الحدود بين العراق وتركيا وبين العراق
وايران طبعا الغايه من هذا التواجد
والتنسيق هو لمنع التسلل وايضا لمنع اي
هجم همم تحاول ان تعكر صفوها الامن
نشر هذه القوات جاء بعد اتفاق بين اربيل
وبغداد خلال زياره رئيس الاقليم لجيرفان
بارزاني الى العاصمه 9 حكومه المركزي
والاقليم الى ايجاد حلل يحول دون تكرار
الهجمات الايرانيه بالطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ والتي تهدد ايران بتحويلها الى
عمليه بريه ما يهم اربيل هو يبعده خطر
صواريخ ايران ومسيراتها الانتحاريه عن
اراضيها والامر مسحوب ايضا على هجمات
تركيا
اربيل قطع الشوطن طويله من المفاوضات مع
بغداد للاتفاق على نشر مزيد من قوات حرس
الحدود العراقي على شرقي حدودها مع ايران
وتركيا تراه هل يرى النور قريبا هذا
الاتفاق
عسكري
اي تقارب اربيل وبغداد السياسيه
تواجد او يعني اعاده انتشار قوات حرس
الحدود على شريط الحدود العراق التركي
الايراني
مع ايران وتركيا مؤخرا الى ان طول الحدود
وعورتها جبالها تحتاج ربما الى اضعاف هذا
الرقم من اربيل احمد الحمداني العربيه